Ja, können Sie anfangen?
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Takye Mezoglu. Ich bin hier der zuständige Arzt.
Bevor wir anfangen, muss ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen
und dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden. Ist das okay für Sie?
Ja, natürlich.
Okay, zuerst, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Paul Müller.
Okay.
Paul Müller.
Herr Müller, könnten Sie bitte Ihren vollen Nachnamen wuchstabilen?
Ja, Paul mit P-A-U-L.
Okay.
Müller, M-U-L-L-E-R.
E-R, okay.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Müller?
Ich bin 68 Jahre alt.
Okay.
Wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 18.09.53.
Wie viel liegen Sie und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,74 groß und wiege 83 kg.
Ein Meter, 77, oder?
Nein, 74.
74, okay.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin jetzt Rentner.
Rentner.
Und vorher, was haben Sie wieder durchgemacht?
War ich in der Verwaltung angestellt.
Ich habe im Büro gearbeitet.
Okay. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, Kinder habe ich und sogar schon ein Enkelkind.
Ah, okay.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
2 Kinder. Die sind natürlich jetzt erwachsen.
Und eben ein Enkelkind.
Herr Müller, was führt Sie zu uns und was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, also ich habe an meinem Bein so eine offene Stelle.
Die habe ich eigentlich schon ganz lange.
Aber jetzt mit einmal wird die verändert, die sich wird größer.
Und mit einmal kommt da auch so eine bräunliche Flüssigkeit raus.
Und ja, das Bein ist auch mit einmal angeschwollen
und sieht einfach nicht gut aus.
Da habe ich jetzt gedacht, ich muss das doch mal jemandem zeigen.
Seit wann haben Sie, Sie haben gesagt seit langem aber?
Ja, das ist bestimmt schon 3,5 Jahre.
Ja, so lange habe ich das schon, schon seit dem Frühjahr.
Aber das war noch nie so schlimm wie jetzt.
Okay. In welchem Bein in Schuldigung?
Am rechten Bein und zwar am innenknöchel.
Innenknöchel auch.
Also das ist schon sehr schmerzhaft.
Und die Schmerzen, die strahlen eigentlich so in den ganzen Unterschenkel rein.
So dass ich auch jetzt eingeschränkt bin beim Laufen und so.
Und ja, das ist wirklich unangenehm.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr stark schmerzlich entspricht?
Ja, ich denke bestimmt bei 5.
So in der Mitte.
Also sie sind nicht unerträglich, aber sie sind halt ständig da.
Und gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen lindert oder verschlechtert?
Ich überlege gerade ja, ich glaube, wenn ich das Bein ein bisschen hoch lege,
dann habe ich das Gefühl, dass das für einen Moment besser.
Und wenn ich jetzt lange unterwegs bin oder so
und viele auf den Beinen, dann sind die Schmerzen stärker.
Gab es irgendetwas in den Sekt bis oder?
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass mich da irgendwas gebissen hat.
Oder vielleicht habe ich mich so minimal angestoßen oder so.
Aber wie das angefangen hat, weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Das ist ja auch schon so lange her.
Und das wollte halt überhaupt nicht zuheilen.
Und jetzt wird es mit einmal so schlecht.
Deswegen habe ich halt gedacht, dann muss ich jetzt mal kommen.
Ja, aber Sie haben ja schon eine gute Entscheidung getroffen.
Und zu uns gekommen.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschmerzen?
Ja, also mir ist halt auch aufgefallen, dass das Bein so ein bisschen spannend jetzt.
Dass das so dicke geworden ist, dass ich so ein bisschen Druckgefühl darauf habe.
Und die Haut sieht auch ein bisschen dunkel verfärbt aus.
Also die sieht nicht so, das ist aber jetzt neu.
Das war nicht schon die ganze Monate so.
Okay.
Gibt es auch Hautrötung oder nur dunkel verfärbt?
Ja, also der ganze Knöchelbereich ist eigentlich eher so dunkel.
Und die direkte Umgebung, wo da diese offene Stelle ist,
das ist natürlich auch gerötet.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber oder haben Sie Fieber gehabt?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, ich fühle mich nicht fieberig.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen übel oder haben Sie erbrochen?
Nein, übel ist mir nicht.
Okay, möchten Sie etwas zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden hinzufügen oder das wars?
Das ist eigentlich das, weshalb ich jetzt hierher gekommen bin.
Genau, ja.
Weil diese offene Stelle immer schlechter wird statt besser.
Und ja, dass ich das mir mal gucken, was man dagegen tun kann.
Okay.
Entschuldigung, ich habe vergessen, haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Tabletten habe ich da nicht eingenommen, nein.
Kann man dagegen Tabletten einnehmen, wüsste ich nicht.
Nein, habe ich aber auch nicht gemacht.
Okay.
Jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen nach Ihrer Krankengestellung stellen.
Leiden Sie an irgendwerche Vorerkrankungen wie zum Beispiel Blutdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, also mein Blutdruck ist schon seit 10 Jahren erhöht.
Okay.
Ja, ich trage seit einigen Jahren ein Hörgerät und da habe ich immer mal so Mittelohrentschuldungen.
Und das kommt relativ, also kommt halt immer wieder.
Und vor drei Wochen war das zuletzt, dass ich da Probleme hatte mit dem Ohr.
Ja.
Und sonst ist es vielleicht noch wichtig, dass ich vor fünf Jahren meine Thrombose im rechten Bein hatte.
Vor fünf Jahren hatten Sie Thrombose im rechten Bein?
Genau.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Nein, bisher noch nicht.
Noch gar nicht.
Okay.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, also meine Mutter ist hoch betagt, aber mein Vater lebt nicht mehr.
Leidet Ihre Mutter an irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, sie hatte eine Darmerkrankung, hat vor acht Jahren einen künstlichen Darmausgang bekommen.
Aber jetzt ist sie auch ja schon so hinfällig und wird im Pflegeheim betreut.
Und mein Vater ist schon lange gestorben.
Woran ist er gestorben, wissen Sie?
Ja, der hatte eine Krebserkrankung, da waren irgendwie die geilen Wege, da hatte er einen Tumor.
Okay.
Und wann ist er gestorben?
Das ist zehn Jahre jetzt her.
Vor zehn Jahren.
Okay.
Entschuldigung, wie alt ist Ihre Mutter?
Ja, die ist, das muss ich eben rechnen, die ist ja in 1989.
Und Sie haben gesagt, Darmerkrankung, aber wissen Sie genau, was Sie da hatten, weiß ich nicht mehr.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein.
Okay.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Bitte?
Meine Kinder?
Ja, die sind gesund.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Ein- oder Durchschlafen?
Ja, manchmal kann ich nicht so gut schlafen, aber bei Unglangerchecken, ja, schlaft.
Genau, ja.
Also, ja, das hängt aber auch ein bisschen damit zusammen, weil ich meine Frau betreue.
Die hatte vor zwei Jahren einen Herzinfarkt und sitzt im Rollstuhl jetzt.
Und wenn die also nachts mal irgendwie zur Toilette muss oder so, dann muss ich ihr halt helfen.
Und dann muss ich immer aufstehen.
Und dadurch schlafe ich natürlich auch nicht so gut, weil ich auch immer horche.
Braucht sie irgendwas und so, ne?
Ja, ja, ich verstehe Sie ganz gut.
Ist Ihr Appetit gut?
Eigentlich ja, doch.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, Wasserlassen geht zum Glück okay, aber ja, beim Stuhlsam habe ich gelegentlich Verstopfung.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie dagegen etwas ein?
Ne, also meistens mache ich so Natur Sachen, dass ich etwas, was ich leinsam einweiche oder getrocknete Pflaumen.
Und dann kann ich mir damit ganz gut helfen.
Okay.
Und seit wann haben Sie diese Probleme?
Ach, bestimmt schon zehn Jahre.
Und, Herr Müller, fühlen Sie sich gestrückt oder niedrige Schlagen?
Ja, manchmal ist das natürlich mit meiner Frau schon eine Herausforderung, dass ich Sie halt versorgen muss.
Und dass ich auch dann im Haus viel Arbeit machen muss, die Sie früher gemacht hat.
Aber grundsätzlich bin ich ja Rentner und habe nicht mehr so viel um die Ohren.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie, der gern müsste ich schon dabei, wir dürfen die Kommentare ein?
Ja klar, gegen den Blutdruck muss ich ja etwas nehmen.
Ich nehme HCT 25, eine morgens.
Dann nehme ich, was haben Sie ein? Entschuldigung, ich konnte abends nicht verschen.
HCT 25.
Okay.
Dann nehme ich zufäno-kriegel, eine morgens und eine abends.
Und dann nehme ich auch noch ASS 100, eine am Tag.
Morgens oder abends?
Mittags.
Mittags nehme ich die.
Okay.
Und HCT, wie viel mal am Tag?
Nehmen ich morgens.
Herr Müller, rauchen Sie?
Ja, seit 18 Jahren rauche ich schon nicht mehr, da bin ich sehr stolz, dass ich das irgendwann mal geschafft habe.
Aber davor habe ich schon viele Jahre ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht.
Okay.
Wissen Sie genau, wie lange?
Ja, von 20 bis 50, also 30 Jahre habe ich geraucht.
Aber jetzt eben schon lange Zeit nicht mehr.
Okay, das ist ja gut.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also gelegentlich trinke ich mal ein Bier, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Eigentlich, okay.
Nehmen Sie sonst gedroben?
Also hören Sie mal, nein, nein, nein.
Ich bin alter Mann, ich nehme nicht solche Sachen.
Okay.
Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien oder Unfertigkeiten bekannt?
Ja, tatsächlich muss ich aufpassen, ich darf also kein Fisch, keine Meeresfrüchte essen.
Da hatte ich schon mal so einen anaphylaktischen Schock.
Das ist, da muss ich also wirklich aufpassen.
Und bei Handcreme bekomme ich manchmal so einen Hautausschlag.
Da kann ich nur ganz bestimmte Sachen benutzen.
Okay, okay, Herr Mner.
Jetzt bin ich mit den Fragen fertig.
Möchten Sie etwas fragen oder hinzufügen?
Eigentlich.
Jetzt möchte ich nur gerne wissen, was Sie mir vielleicht empfehlen,
dass ich tun soll, damit diese Runde zugeht.
Deswegen bin ich ja hier und was wir gegen die Schmerzen machen können.
Ja, natürlich.
Wie gesagt, es ist schon gut, dass Sie zu uns gekommen sind.
Wir geben unser Bestes, um die Ursachen ihrer Beschwerden herauszufinden
und Sie bestmöglich zu behandeln.
Aber es ist zu früh, etwas komplettes zu sagen.
Ich werde Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen
und dann nehme ich Ihnen Blut ab.
Und ich mache bei Ihnen
einen Ultraschall von Ihrem Bein, rechten Bein
und einen Gründeraufnahme von Ihrem Bein
und dann können wir genauer besprechen.
Okay, gut.
Ich ordne ein Schmerzmittel sofort für Sie an.
Ja, das ist sehr gut, ja.
Okay, jetzt können Sie im Wartesblatt nehmen.
Ja, dann warte ich da auf Sie.
Ja, und dann bin ich wieder gleich bei Ihnen.
Super.
Ja, gibt es ergänzende Fragen von irgendjemandem?
Darf ich etwas fragen?
Immer, hallo, fast mal.
Hallo, guten Abend.
40 Ehrerbein warm an?
Oh, gute Frage.
Ich glaube nicht.
Also wärmer als das andere.
Dass es richtig wärmer, als das linke ist.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Ja?
Sie haben gesagt vor fünf Jahren,
da haben Sie Ihre rechte Bein, eine Trombos gehabt.
Und ich würde gerne ein bisschen, haben Sie damals das behandelt?
Wie waren Sie das behandelt?
War sie im Krankenhaus?
Gut, ja.
Kann ich etwas zu sagen?
Ich habe natürlich deiner Zeit Herparien bekommen
und dann Makomaf für ein halbes Jahr.
Ich habe auch einen Kompressionsstruf getragen.
Für ein halbes Jahr.
Das war eine Unterschenkel-Wien-Trombose.
Da bin ich behandelt worden,
aber seitdem habe ich mich da nicht mehr darum gekümmert.
Damals hatten Sie Atemprobleme?
Nein.
Ich habe nur beschränkt auf die Beinwände.
Okay, danke.
Und zu meiner Frage.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben Ausfluss
aus der Wunderbemerkung.
Wie sieht der Ausfluss aus?
Und wie ist der Ausfluss über der Ecke?
Wie ist der Ausfluss?
Das letzte habe ich nicht verstanden.
Wie sieht der Ausfluss aus?
Okay, jetzt habe ich das verstanden.
Riechend habe ich jetzt nicht beschrieben.
Aber ich weiß,
dass es eine bräunliche Flüssigkeit ist.
Gelb nicht steht da nicht.
Ich weiß, ich arbeite definitiv nicht.
Okay, ich glaube, wir können, oder?
Dass wir weiter machen mit der Präsentation zum Oberart?
Ja, okay.
Oder ist noch nicht so weit?
Oder bist du noch nicht so weit?
Nein, nein, wir können machen, aber ich brauche 1, 2 Minuten.
Ja, ja, alles gut.
Der Patient sitzt ja gut und wartet zu machen.
Ja, ich habe versucht.
Jetzt geht es los.
Hallo, Frau Oberstein.
Ja, hallo.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Ja, wie haben Sie denn gesehen?
Erzählen Sie mal.
Okay.
Entschuldigung, einen neuen Patient.
Der Patient heißt Paul Müller.
Er ist 68 Jahre alt.
Er ist Rentner, verheiratet und hat 2 Kinder.
Er kam heute zu uns
wegen Ödemi
und einer offenen Stelle.
Er ist ein sehr guter Patient.
Er ist auf einer offenen Stelle im rechten Bein.
Es gibt bräunliche Humor in dieser Stelle.
Er leidet unter Schmerzen im rechten Bein.
Wo ist denn die offene Stelle lokalisiert?
Er hat gesagt,
im rechten
in den Kinochell,
und die Umgebung
in der Umgebung
von dieser offenen Stelle
gibt es ein Romantik.
Aber die
Die Malloros medialis und die umgebung dunkel verfärbt ist dunkel verfärbt.
Er hat wie gesagt auch schmerzen und die schmerzen stahlen auch in den ganzen unterchenkel.
Er hat keine Verletzung oder keine Insekten genannt und er hat gesagt diese Stelle gab es seit langem, aber jetzt schlimmer geworden.
Wie lange hat er die offene Stelle schon?
Er hat gesagt seit dem Frühjahr seit ein paar Monaten.
Und seit wann hat er sich verschlechtert?
Ich habe das verpasst, aber seit einigen Tagen.
Er hat gesagt, seit einigen Tagen.
Er hat keine Fieber oder die Fragen nach Fieber, Nausia und Fomitus wurden verneint.
Er bewertet die Schmerzintensität mit fünf auf der Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10.
Wenn er sein Bein hochlegt, wird es besser oder geht es ihm besser.
Und wenn er zu viel läuft, wird es ihm schlimmer.
Vielleicht auch?
Wir sind in Schämen für Erkrankungen.
Er leidet seit zehn Jahren Artil-Löw-Bertonie.
Seit einigen Jahren trägt er ein Hörgerät und bekommt häufig Autotys-Media.
Vor fünf Jahren hat er Trombose in seinem Ressent-Bein.
Er wurde nie operiert.
Familienalmese ergab.
Mutter lebt in der Pflegeheim.
Und vor acht Jahren ist er in der Iliostoma.
Er ist vor zehn Jahren in Kolangio.
Die vegetative Analyse ist unaufhörlich bis auf Insomnia und Obstpation.
Er fühlt sich gestresst.
Er ist wegen der Pflege seiner Frau.
Was ist mit der Frau?
Er hatte vor zwei Jahren Mio-Card-Infarkt.
Jetzt ist sie im Rohrstuhl.
Er hat natürlich viel zu tun.
Er kümmert sich um seine Frau.
Er nimmt Medikamente mit 25 mg Hydrochlorothea-Cit.
Einmal morgens, dann am April, dann morgens und dann abends.
Und dann ausbringt er 100 mg Mittags.
Er ist seit 18 Jahren nicht Trauer.
Er hat 30 Jahre lang eine Piction.
Er gibt einen gelegentlichen Alkoholkonsum von ein Bier.
Die Frage nach Drogen wurde verneint.
Er hat Fischallergie.
Er reagiert darauf an Anaphylaktik-Show.
Er hat auch Allergie gegen Handcreme.
Er reagiert darauf mit Exantin.
Sehr gut.
Was ist jetzt Ihre Vermutung, was dem Menschen fehlt?
Die bisherigen an amnestischen Angaben
haben am Hessen auf eine Trombofilevitis in Bayern.
Dafür sprechen Ödem in der Restlinne.
Ödem und Rohrnischehmoa.
Aber der hat eine offene Stelle.
Eine Hauptentzündung, aber was hat er?
Wie nennen wir so ein richtiges noch in Bayern?
Post-Rombotisches-Zentrum.
Möglicherweise ist es das.
Wie man sich das jetzt festtiert?
Es kam eben schriftlich rein.
Hast du gesehen?
Die hat ja natürlich.
Er hat ein post-rombotisches Zentrum.
Das heißt Ulcus crudis.
Richtig.
Und in diesem Fall ein Ulcus crudis venosum.
Das ist unsere Verdachtsdiagnose.
Was könnte es unter Amstetten noch sein?
Wenn wir jetzt vielleicht auch ein bisschen die Vorgeschichte vernachlässigen würden,
das könnte es differentialdiagnose zu schnock sein.
Erlisipel oder Cellulitis?
Cellulitis?
Ja.
Okay.
Also Erlisipel, ja, aber dazu passt er die offene Stelle nicht.
Wenn es kein venoses Ulcus wäre, was könnte es da noch sein?
Ja, ein altarielles.
Artäriere oder Diabetik?
Ein diabetesches Fußsyndrom.
Kann man auch nicht ausschließen.
Wir wissen zwar nichts von dem Diabetes von diesem Patient.
Und auch in der Familie in Anamnese kommt kein Diabetes vor.
Aber ausschließen kann man es natürlich nicht.
Und wo ist das?
Das ist ein Diabetes, kann man es natürlich nicht.
Und gut.
Und dann noch ganz exotisch, das muss man aber wahrscheinlich dann auch
nach der klinischen Untersuchung ins Auge fassen.
Was könnte es schlimmstenfalls noch sein?
Skolmoselcarcinoma.
Ja, genau.
Aus der dann Piodermagangrenosum, Leveduitasculitia.
Die 3. Ambainafia.
Das wird sehr speziell, hat man es Hautärztin, ne?
Ja.
Osteomyelitis können wir sagen, Osteomyelitis.
Da werden ja die Knochen betroffen.
Dann wohnen die sehr tiefe.
Ja, ich meine man sieht es ja schon manchmal, ne?
Dass man die Wunden hat, wo man bis auf den Knochen durchgucken kann.
Aber so schlimm ist es bei mir, Gott sei Dank.
Ja, ja.
Gut, ja.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt, um rauszufinden, was mit dem Patienten ist?
Was machen Sie, wie gehen Sie vor im Weiteren?
Okay.
Ja, ich würde nach der köperlichen Untersuchung und Blutabnahme
eine Sonografie...
Ja, was machen Sie denn bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Wo nach gucken Sie denn da? Besonders?
Ah, Köperliche Untersuchung.
Okay.
Die Pulse.
Yes.
Ja, am Fußgeling.
Wie heißen die beiden?
Wie bitte?
Welche Fußpulse tasten Sie?
Arteriatemilanes.
Arterio und ADP, Arteria, Dorvalis, Pedis.
Ja, ja, Dorvalis, Pedis und...
Ja, so.
Gut, und ja, was machen Sie da noch?
Und ich untersuche die Odemen.
Ja, genau.
Ja, ich partiere und ich gucke, ob es wegdruckbar ist.
Gut, also dann machen Sie Labor
und das machen Sie an technischen Untersuchungen.
Sonografie des Beins.
Yes.
Duplex, Sonografie eigentlich.
Duplex, genau.
Und wo nach gucken Sie dann?
In der Sonografie oder?
Ja, wo nach gucken Sie beim Duplex, genau, in der Sonografie.
Okay.
Die Durchblutung von diesem Bereich.
Ja, wir lösen Schluss und Arteriatress gekriegt.
Und beim Labor, worauf achten Sie da?
Was haben Sie da angekreuzt?
Die Blutbild- und Entzündungsparameter wie CRP.
Noch mal bitte.
Also ich habe das Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter und danach...
Ich habe gesagt Entzündungsparameter wie CRP.
Ach so, ja, genau.
Und das noch?
Wenn wir uns über die durchgemachte Thrombose nachdenken...
Ja, die mehrere.
Ja, und wenn wir über ein diabetesches Fußsyndrom nachdenken...
HBR1C?
Ja, oder Glukose erst mal, ja, HBR1C, genau.
Ja, das ist doch schon mal schön.
Gut, ja, da haben wir die Antike.
Und ja, was würde man denn noch machen,
wenn man jetzt eine offene Stelle hat am Bein?
Labortechnisch.
Man kann Kultur durchführen.
Sehr gut.
Ja, zuerst dem Riedemann.
Der Riedemann.
Ja, macht man nicht erst den Abstrich, bevor man coolt?
Wie bitte?
Macht man nicht erst den Abstrich diagnostisch, bevor man anfängt, da zu debridieren?
Man macht doch erst den Abstrich diagnostisch.
Ja, man kann einen Abstrich nehmen, zum Beispiel, um Kultur zu machen.
Und wonach müssen die unter anderem besonders gucken?
Was ist denn heute so ein Problem in Krankenhäusern?
Also jetzt rede ich nicht von Corona.
Vor der Corona-Meinung.
Vor Corona, ja.
Meinen Sie MRSA?
Ja, ja, ja, genau. MRSA, ne?
Ja.
Wenn nämlich zum Beispiel diese MRSA positiv wäre,
haben wir ja das Problem, wir müssen Untersuchungsraum dichtmachen.
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Und müssen den Grund reinigen, ja, da sind so Geschichten.
Muss der Patient sofort in Isolation reinigen, oder?
Also eigentlich, glaube ich, macht man im Vorfeld bei Verdacht auf MRSA.
Man fragt vorher Risikofaktoren ab.
Ja, also zumindest ist das meine Erfahrung aus den Jahren im Krankenhaus.
Wir haben tatsächlich in der letzten Zeit das so gemacht,
dass wir Risikofaktoren für, wenn wir wussten, es kommt jemand mit offenen Beinen,
ja, mit dem Ulkos.
Das wird ja angemeldet. Warum kommt der Patient?
Dann macht man die Absfrage und sagt, sind Sie in letzter Zeit im Krankenhaus gewesen,
betreuen Sie eine pflegebedürftige Person,
arbeiten Sie in der Krankenpflege,
arbeiten Sie in der Landwirtschaft.
Was weiß ich, also den ganzen Fragenkatalog.
Ja, und wenn dann einer von den Punkten positiv ist,
dann macht man erstmal Mund- und Nasenabstrich
und nimmt praktisch einen Raum, den man hinterher sicherheitshalber dicht machen kann.
Damit man im Zweifelsfall das nicht weiter trägt.
Und dann müssen eigentlich auch die Mitarbeiter mit Mund-Nasen-Schutz,
Kopfhau-Behand-Schuhen-Schutzkittel die Untersuchung machen.
Das wird aber, glaube ich, weiß ich nicht,
ob das tatsächlich immer noch, immer noch subfaktiziert wird.
Vielleicht haben wir heute andere Sorgen, keine Ahnung.
Aber zumindest ist das ein Aspekt, den man im Kopf haben muss.
Offene Runde mit MRSA.
Gut, ja.
Dann haben Sie noch etwas, haben Sie noch etwas gesagt zum Patienten?
Sie wollten den Röntgen.
Was wollten Sie röntgen?
Man könnte untersuchen, ob die Knochen betroffen sind.
Okay, ja.
Aber ich glaube erst in zweiter Linie.
Erstmal ist das Duplex die Untersuchung der Wahl.
Gut, wenn sich das jetzt alles bestätigt,
der hat ein venöses Ulkust.
Wie ist denn die Behandlung von den Patienten?
Was machen Sie denn mit dem?
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das habe.
Ich sage noch mal die Wunden-Nest.
Was steht der so wieder raus?
Nein, ich glaube.
Sondern der Patient muss in Krankenhaus bleiben.
Aufgenommen werden.
Und dann zuerst Antibiotherapie.
Den nachdem wieder Abstrich ausfällt.
Aber muss der tatsächlich zwingend statt so eine Aufgenommen werden?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube, der hat die Abstrich-Krankenhaus.
Und dann muss der tatsächlich zwingend stationär aufgenommen werden?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Also eigentlich muss der nicht stationär behandelt werden.
Aber was machen Sie denn?
Der kann ja jetzt nicht so wieder nach Hause gehen
mit seinem offenen Bein, mit seinem Loch am Innenknöchel.
Was machen Sie denn da drauf?
Wir können die Wunden desinfizieren zuerst.
Zum Beispiel, ja.
Und das Ding Nest.
Und dann muss der auf die Flüssigkeit raus.
Also, was machen Sie drauf?
Also, Debre de Man?
Ja, Debre de Man, haben Sie schon gesagt.
Aber dann wird das ja auch nicht aufhören zu messen.
Da muss da erst mal eine saugtfiehgewund Auflage drauf.
Irgendwas, was die Flüssigkeit aufsaugt.
Da gibt es auch so super Absorberzeug.
Ja, das weiß Fatma wahrscheinlich besser.
Ob das immer noch Axel Edd ist,
dass man so silberhaltige Sachen zum Beispiel macht,
weil die desinfizieren auch Fatma.
Ja, ja, ja.
Richtig.
Hydrogen und Silberzusatia.
Ja, siehst du, genau.
Ja, genau.
Und dann, was macht man noch?
Also, der hat da seinen Wundverband.
Super saugtfieh.
Und das kommt danach?
Verband.
Bitte?
Kompression, Therapie.
Yes.
Verband.
Ja, ja, Kompressionsverband.
Der kriegt einen schönen,
der kriegt einen schönen,
dreilagigen Kompressionsverband.
Ja.
Und wenigstens bis,
bis, ja, Unterschenkel.
Und wenn das dann,
wenn das dann,
wenn das dann dabei bleibt,
wenn er, wenn er da also mit klarkommt,
dann muss er irgendwann
einen Kompressionstumpf kriegen.
Also, da gibt es spezielle Kompressionstrumpfe,
die noch so einen,
so einen Unterstrumpf haben,
der,
der besser gewaschen werden kann.
Die heißen Alzacare.
Also,
der Kompressionstumpf jedenfalls unter drunter,
erst mal diese saufige Auflage.
Gut, das ist das Mittel der Wahl.
Muss der Bedroh halten?
Oder darf der rumlaufen?
Ich denke, kann der Patient laufen?
Der soll laufen, genau.
Mobilisierung, genau.
Ja, gut.
Und wenn wir jetzt festgestellt haben,
der hat tatsächlich,
der hat tatsächlich also
da, da
Krampfadern und
schlechte, schlechte
Wenenverhältnisse.
Was ist dann auf Dauer
das Mittel der Wahl?
Was macht man dann?
Der Patient nimmt schon aus Briehen.
Ja.
Das kann operiert werden, aber
Was machen wir denn da?
Ich kann den Namen von der Operation
nicht erinnern oder an den Namen.
Ja, also man kann ja
zwei verschiedene Sachen, man kann entweder die Wenen
strippen, ja,
oder man kann Sklerotherapie machen.
Ja, Sklerotherapie.
Ja, oder so eine Verö凍stherapie.
Aber also wenn das kleine Dinger sind,
kann man die, kann man die verögen
und die großen, wenn deine Stammwene betroffen ist,
die,
warte mal, wie heißt das noch?
Die kann man auch lasern.
Kann man mit Laseropie auch machen.
Es strippen oder lasern
und die kleinen mit Sklerotherapie.
Genau.
Und damit müsste dann das,
das Ulkos auch eine Chance haben,
abzuhäilen.
Wenn da also praktisch die Grundlage entzogen wird,
die Wenenschwäche wird therapiert.
Der wird,
die Wunde wird sauber gehalten
und trocken gehalten.
Ja.
Und wird komprimiert.
Damit hat er eine Chance,
dass das Ding zuheilt.
Ja.
Alles klar.
Darf ich etwas sagen?
Gerne, bitte.
Wissen Sie, Mardenterapie.
Oh, ja.
Hab ich tatsächlich schon erlebt.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass es bei so ganz hoffnungslosen Patienten,
wo die Wunden um nichts in der Welt zuheilen wollten,
setzt man tatsächlich Marden drauf.
Das hat erstaunlich guten Effekt.
Aber es ist natürlich allein der Gedanke ein bisschen gruselig.
Ja.
Aber das, was ich als noch relativ neues gehört habe,
ich weiß nicht, das weiß ich wahrscheinlich auch,
fragt mal jetzt.
Hast du gehört von Fischhaut-Transplantation?
Es gibt tatsächlich
einen Transplantat,
was aus echter Fischhaut hergestellt worden ist.
Ich weiß nicht,
wie der welche Firma das macht.
Das ist tatsächlich auch für so ganz hoffnungslose Fälle,
wo großflächige Ulter sind.
Das ist ja auch ein Teil der Wunde.
Das ist ja auch eine Möglichkeit,
wenn man großflächige Ulzerationen hat.
Dass man ein Mesh aus dem Oberschenkel oder aus dem Bauch nimmt
und damit abdeckt.
Das ist tatsächlich, das ist eine Option.
Ja.
Aber das ist das, was ich für ein Transplantat habe.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass es auch nicht so gut ist.
Das ist ja auch eine Möglichkeit.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass es auch nicht so gut ist.
Aber dieser Patient,
der hat ja tatsächlich nur eine kleine offene Stelle am Bein.
Am Unterschenkel.
Man kann sich das kaum vorstellen.
Was auch so Beine entwerden kann.
Wie die sich auch entwickeln,
wenn die halt nicht therapiert werden.
Da ist dann irgendwann,
wenn die Zeit zu weit fortgeschritten ist,
muss man halt zu solchen relativ
invasiven Maßnahmen greifen.
Auslässlich Chance.
Ja.
Ja, ist ja bekloppt,
wenn jemand praktisch sich überhaupt nicht kümmert.
Es gibt ja viele Leute,
denen ist das egal, was mit ihren Beinen ist.
Die gucken die auch nicht an.
Bevor man amputiert,
ist das total kaputt.
Klar,
versucht man da erstmal mit allen Mitteln sonst
irgendwas zu unternehmen,
dass die Haut wieder dicht geht.
Gut.
Ja.
Dann können wir unseren Patienten, also nach Verband,
nach Hause schicken
und geben ihm natürlich das Rezept mit
einer kompressionsstrümpfe,
damit er die regelmäßig trägt.
Er soll vielleicht zu seinem Haus ausgehen,
regelmäßig zum Verband wechseln,
solange das Ding zu ist.
Wieder Vorstellung in,
das weiß ich, ein Monat oder so.
Alles klar.
Gut.
Wie geht es dir?
Dr.
Besser.
Besser als vorher.
Besser als letztes Mal.
Okay.
Nachher beim Vorgehen,
da hat natürlich
ein bisschen der Background gefehlt.
Was hast du beruflich
für Abteilungen gearbeitet?
Ich bin Allgemeinmediziner.
Aber ich bin kein Verratz.
Allgemeinmediziner sehen ja auch irgendwann mal
auch eine Beine in der Praxis.
Da muss man einem doch eigentlich auch etwas zu einfallen.
Ja.
Klar, ich sag natürlich auch,
ich bin ein Verrat.
Das ist ja,
das ist ja, was man nicht alle Tage macht.
Was soll man dazu sagen?
Gut.
Ja, ich gebe zu,
dass das natürlich für mich auch so ein Bereich ist.
Wenn ich sonst von Medizin ja nicht viel Ahnung habe,
aber in dem Bereich weiß ich ein bisschen Bescheid
aus meiner Berufstätigkeit.
Ja, dann kommen wir das für heute, glaube ich, beenden.